The Joe Rogan experience. So did you look
at the heart before they put it in you?
Did you get a chance to see it?
No, no, no. I was out. Yeah.
It was out by that time. Yeah.
Wow. Nope. Didn't look anything.
So you wake up, lights come back on. Yep.
And uh, doctors, every
wipes, they're doctors.
They're my wife's there. And
uh, it was, uh, you know,
a new day and I was like, uh,
I want, I kind of wanted to,
I kind of wanted to say,
and I told you so. Yeah.
That was the first pop. That's
hilarious. Do so told you.
So it was a funny thing to say.
Would you come back from a heart
transplant because you would be a,
you would be surprised at how many so
funny though if you did say that. So true.
So it was so many.
I got so many people and it
was overwhelming support,
but I got quite a few,
well, too many for me, uh,
messages with the engine. I hope you
don't make it. I hope you die and your,
I wish we did already
know stuff like that.
Do you feel I'm sorry for
those people now? Oh yeah.
Most definitely now. Now I do, you know,
instead of being angry
before and I was like,
yeah, you don't choke the shit out of him.
But you know, now, I mean, you gotta be,
um, what, what is your,
your existence must be pretty
pitiful for you to, you know,
feel that much hate for somebody that
you don't even know, never even met.
I just can't stand Joe Rogan.
I hate him.
I've never met him.
My niggers sit down.
There's no happy people that are
doing that. It's so transparent.
You gotta be pretty, you know, pump
believably miserable, miserable,
miserable. I'm a file of Joe Rogan
just so I can talk shit about them.
I don't care.
I wish Joe Rogan was off the air,
but I'm following every
word he says because I don't
want to miss nothing to Joe
Rogan has to say, but I hate them.
Yeah. Makes no sense, man. Well,
it doesn't make sense, but a lot of
people don't make sense. That's true.
People live their lives and just very
counterproductive ways and they feel like
as long as they've got something,
they're excited about that,
that they're doing something,
even if it's excited about hating
you for no reason, man. I just,
I don't get it. Time is too precious
to waste on hate. It's just foolish.
It's just, yeah, it's a foolish way to
exist. Yeah. I can take, they can take,
uh,
livers and hearts and different origins
from any nationality and switching
around were interchangeable.
Joe.
We are interchangeable or all one thing.
Yes.
The only thing that separates us is the
climate that we came from. That's it.
That's it. So, and it, it,
it, it makes racism. So
everything's stupid. Tribalism of stupid
across the board. The conservative
versus liberal,
that stupid southern versus northern bat.
Stupid to Asian versus black
versus Pakistani stupid.
It's all super. Those boots. All stupid.
We're are any boat dude.
We were all back there right there.
So, you know, we all one,
we wouldn't be entertained.
It's this outer shit that's on top,
this epidermis, the skin,
this stuff that, you know,
the fights and it's what
makes us interesting.
Shabbat it,
it's like what's fascinating to me is
that human beings came from every single
spot on the earth.
Yeah.
One time they originated in Africa
and spread out all over the planet.
Gapped individual environment. When you
meet someone from Ireland, they're white,
like paper. That shit's just because
there's no sun that body developed.
It's like a, a solar panel for vitamin
D. They're like, we've got to figure out,
I get fucking vitamin D, this black
skinny cut, no fucking son out here.
We don't need this melon.
And cause we're not protecting
ourselves from the sun anymore.
So they turned white. Yes.
Did the same exact thing.
Megan,
take that guy from Ireland,
guy from African and this
guy needs a part. It's, hey,
let me switch it up.
This gentleman here,
Graham Hancock was on my podcast
last week and he's a brilliant,
brilliant guy,
but he studies ancient civilizations
and people and one of the things that
they're studying now is,
um,
the various civilizations that we didn't
even know existed that existed in South
America.
Like huge,
multimillion size of population,
um,
civilizations in the Amazon,
like 20 million people living in the
Amazon at one point in time and they think
they were wiped out by Spanish explorers.
Um,
in European explorers that
came over game smallpox,
like the way they've gone wiped
out 90% of the native Americans.
They think the same thing happened
down there in the Amazon. It just,
they had huge cities down there that
European settlers had reported on.
They were just wiped out.
But the point is that we are,
we were everywhere and it's all one thing.
It's all humans.
Human race.
That's it man.
And the funny thing about white people
that are racist is that especially like I
have a neanderthal DNA does more primitive
than homosapien DNA and it's only in
white people. Like, it's kind of
funny that way, you know, cause white,
white racists,
like they have to deal with the fact
that the only white people carry that in
the Anatol shitting them.
Yeah.
And do you think that,
I don't think that they would find that a,
a bad thing
after neanderthal DNA? No, I think
they'd be a oh yeah. Oh, right. Yeah.
They weren't smart enough to
stick around for whatever reason.
I don't even know why,
you know,
they don't know if we out bred them or
we interbred with them or if we wiped
them out when they don't
even know what they,
they're also finding new humans there.
There's um,
a human they found in
Russia called a Dennis,
I think it's called Dennis
Sullivan is that he's had,
and they just found more
bones of them in Tibet.
So they know that these Russian people,
that was a totally distinct
sub species of human traveled,
traveled to Tibet. Yeah. And,
and neanderthals lived
for half a million years,
so they were around way longer than
weaver. We've only been around,
I think for a couple of hundred
thousand years. Homo sapiens. Yeah.
So they were around longer than us,
like by a factor of like somewhere
around 300,000 years. Yeah.
All over the world, man. Just
what a crazy animal we are.
We just travel everywhere and find
a spot and adapt. That's right.
We make it work.
Stay in a community so you can help
each other and live off each other and
adapt. And unfortunately that's
where all tribalism comes from too.
That we have this tight knit group and
everybody else, fuck everybody else.
It's US versus them. And
that's inside of us. You know,
we met, wouldn't it be great and, and,
and this where I don't
think that it's wrong.
If you're attacking guy,
I don't think it's wrong to be
very proud of being Italian. I,
and if you're a Polish guy,
I don't think it's, uh,
wrong to be very proud of being imposed.
Why can't I be proud?
Or why can't you be proud of
being whatever race you are.
You can be proud of that.
But there's that me that I have to
hate another guy because he's not,
no.
The racing game.
You can be proud of what you are and
not hate another guy for being different
than what you are. How?
How about we give dad
try? Well, I think the feeling that
you got from the second chance on life,
this beautiful feeling of appreciation
and celebration of, of this existence,
that's what we need to try to foster
in people. Oh, we need to try to like,
let people know this is, this
is a temporary thing, man.